when they say you're going to join an
Indiana Jones movie and then you get
there and it's Harrison Ford is it just
mind-blowing the entire thing completely
mind-blowing
I actually couldn't believe every single
day I was on set the note I got most was
can you please stop smiling that's the
whole time I was just like what's
happening it'll be far too much fun
people yeah it was so much fun I
couldn't believe I was allowed to do it
there's so many amazing stunts and these
incredible places we went to it's just a
dream come true honestly I'm presumably
some emotional moments too as Harrison
Ford
yeah of course yeah yeah it had a real
gravitas the whole experience actually
and even when we were doing the sort of
mad cat fun stuff every now and again it
would hit us that this is you know the
last adventure he's gonna go on and it's
um yeah it's very meaningful and I feel
like you know I think it's very obvious
how meaningful it is to Harrison and you
know we were all on that Journey with
him so it's a real privilege